foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
now welcome back we're going to answer
some of your questions about the
Chancellor's statement today in which
Jeremy Hunt uh got rid of most of the
tax cuts announced by his predecessor
one or two of them stayed under
announced an early end to the energy
price cup so lots to discuss then with
my expert panel joining me is Greg Marsh
founder and CEO of the cost of living
tool and mouse we've got jeevan sander
head of Economics at the new economics
Foundation think tanker and alongside
him Sue Hayward consumer affairs and
personal finance experts so we've got
all the bases covered I hope because
we've got an awful lot of questions
coming in from our viewers and listeners
covering a wide range of topics we're
going to jump straight end in with our
first question it's about mortgage rates
which of course is worrying so many many
people thousands of people tens of
thousands it comes from Laura and Laura
says uh the broad Point what impact will
these reversals have on mortgage rates
and when would we expect them to start
going down jeevan you take this one
because mortgage rates depend on the
prices on what's going on in the bond
market just explain yes I don't have any
good news too on that sense at the
moment the banking the base rate is
about 2.25 we still expect that to go
over five percent next year so for every
percentage Point increase on your more
on the banking and base rate which then
hits mortgage rates it's about 600
pounds for every hundred thousand pounds
that you owe so we're still looking at
large increases in mortgage payments
over the next few years and indeed
people have to refinance it you know in
one sense why is it why of interest
rates driven risen over this time it's
because of an incompetency premium now
today Jeremy I mean competency premium
yes exactly where we are the phrase
that's exactly where we are people don't
have faith in British policy making ever
since Liz trust came into government now
Jeremy to put kind of the brakes on some
of it and he's a bit more competent so
it's come down a little bit we were
expecting six percent but it will still
be much much higher so not much not out
of the woods yet so well we've got
plenty of questions on mortgages so
we'll take uh the next one from Connor
Cunningham this is about fixed rates
that we were discussing there that I
think the majority of people are now on
when it comes to mortgages Sue tell us
about this so this one Carl says my
two-year fixed rate mortgage ends in May
2023 so what six seven months time uh
what do these new measures mean for me
will we still see a rise in mortgages to
between 4.5 and 6 percent as jeevan was
saying I mean how long is a piece of
string we just don't know do we we don't
I mean the majority of people as you say
are on fixed rate there's only around 2
million homeowners who are on the
standard variable rate right now or
possibly even Peg to the the tracker
rate which usually follows the bank of
England
um so with fixed rates yes there's no
good news sadly and that they're not
suddenly likely to to fall and the
problem is that we saw over a thousand
different mortgage products being taken
off the market in the wake of the mini
budget simply because the lenders
panicked and they also thought hang on
we need to take these away and reprice
them before we put them back out on the
shelves so to speak simply because they
weren't going to be offering the cheaper
Deals they had been in the wake of the
potential Bank of England Rises going
even higher because the end of the day
they are businesses they're there to
make money so they wanted to make sure
that they weren't going to be pricing
mortgages too cheaply and people would
snap them up you know even five years or
even longer so right now I mean the
mortgage rates you know almost well the
fixed rates are sort of double what they
were you know even a year ago so it's
not yeah not great news Greg um take
give us your thoughts on that as well
but the question then as I say so many
people worried about them or would just
Helen just asked this simply and it's
about timing should I fix my mortgage or
wait yeah the challenge Helen and others
of us face is that trust comes on foot
but it leaves on Horseback and trust
with the teeth with a t that's right
that's trust um we'll see whether Liz
truss is also leaving quickly or not
time to tell look the challenges that
although exactly who says there will be
a return to uh cheaper deals if indeed
expectations around interest rates uh
interest rate Rises full but that will
take time and Banks I think have had to
act with urgency to withdraw a lot of
their cheaper deals which means that for
a period of time there are no really
cheap deals in the market and even
though today's
rollback on pricing has meant that there
will be probably some optimism over the
course of next year that we might not
see Bank of England base rates get as
high as six percent expectation now as
that Conway was saying earlier Ron close
to five percent than six percent which
means that mortgage rates if you were to
wait until this time next summer before
you refinanced it might not be as bad as
it could have been it might only be
seven eight percent rather than 809
percent but context matters you probably
took out your current fixed rate deal
when Bank of england-based rates were
sub 1 which means you're going to see
your mortgage whatever happens roughly
double maybe even more in terms of the
cost of interest repayments every year
so there's a real challenge do you do
that refinancing today do you pay your
early repayment charge get it over with
and get a deal in before it's going to
get even more expensive or do you hold
out and hope for the best that rates
haven't risen even further by next year
Well Sue what about going for uh going
for a Tracker because if you're looking
at 2.25 okay even if the bank of England
puts it up to three percent uh in in
November and you're tracking what about
0.75 or one percent above that you're
still going to be below the fixed rates
at the moment potentially but I suppose
the problem is for a lot of people they
want to be able to budget they want to
know what's happening and certainly in
light of today's news as well about the
fact that the energy price guarantee
isn't going to last two years come April
energy bills could be on the rise again
in fact they will be unless the
government is going to sort out you know
some help for certain people but for
majority of people they'll be on the
rise I think most people want to know so
they can budget month to month what
they're paying for so what the fixed
deals yes you may pay slightly over the
odds because it's a fix you're looking
into but you will know what you're
paying in the future and of course it's
worth saying that if you are coming to
the end of a fix within the last three
to six months of a fix you can look to
remortgage and shop around you don't
have to wait till you'll fix deal ends
and then say right it's ended I'm now on
the standard variable let's shop around
now you've got that same kind of book it
absolutely but Jim just on on the way
fixed rates are sorted out I mean
they're not actually linked to the bank
of England rate are they that those
lenders are getting that money in the
market so it's those guilt rates that
the matter the bonds it does indeed and
look does we've seen those have all
course risen at the other end if you
like they are rising faster and higher
than the bank rate but the reason why
guilts arise in the forward so like the
10 year and the 30 is because they're
expecting buyer interest rates from the
bank in the future and that's because
they're expecting higher inflation after
the mini Budget on top of that
incompetency premium so all of those
things come together to mean that
actually it's just going to cost
families and households hundreds of
pounds compared to where we were when
that budget was released I think four
weeks ago and that's mortgages now let's
get on to energy bills it's so much of
an assault on so many fronts on
household budgets um let's put this to
you Greg after the announcement this
question says after the announcement
about the energy price cap only lasting
until April and this is quite an about
turn will this mean that after this date
we will all be looking at higher bills
of five to six thousand pounds a year I
mean it's capped at two and a half
thousand pounds at the moment yeah I was
really struck by something that Jeremy
Hunt said today in his statement he said
it would not be responsible I quote to
continue exposing public finances to
unlimited volatility in international
gas prices so by withdrawing at least
this thing standard unless there's a
change of policy by withdrawing that
fixed rate that we all had going for us
after April the public finances aren't
going to be exposed to that uncertainty
but that means that our private finances
will be exposed to that uncertainty and
none of us know one of the leading
energy consulting firms earlier this
afternoon said that they thought that a
a typical household would see their
energy prices probably increased to
something like four four and a half
thousand pounds after April next year
which would effectively be about another
150 pounds a month for a typical
household it could be it could be as
good as that or it could as the question
asks be a lot worse than that the The
crucial Factor here is the much higher
level of uncertainty that we're all now
having to operate under as households as
well as as a country and that
uncertainty I think really is causing
people a lot of anxieties individual
households it's really hard to budget
under that level of uncertainty Sue but
one imagines that it wouldn't just scrap
that cap altogether it will become more
targeted under the current scheme I mean
it really is a blunderbuss there are
households who can't afford it's going
to be unpleasant but there are
households who who can't afford to pay
the higher prices so we're still getting
the support absolutely and this is where
they had to go in with something and I
think the problem is with any of this
support if they've got to do it in a
hurry which they seem to want to do Rush
something out they then did a sort of
generic you know one size fit so all
rather than targeting support you know
for example the way that the cost of
living payment the 650 payment targeted
to certain people with this it was just
quick let's roll it out and that was the
quickest easiest way for them to do it
at the time one would imagine which is
why now they're thinking that's going to
cost us an awful lot of money what are
we now going to do about it but of
course the problem is people now
dependent thinking we were going to get
two years on a price Capital guarantee
may have even been the process of
thinking well if we move house we may
have a slightly bigger house but we can
afford the bills because you know if we
monitor the heating although obviously
it wasn't the price the bills weren't
fixed it was the price or the cap on the
energy unit but it's still in general
you had an idea what your bills might be
so people may have taken all sorts of
other routes now thinking they were
going to be protected by this and
they're not and we should also remember
as well that a clear failure here was
that there was no plan as to what was
going to happen when the energy price
freeze ends you know we thought gas
prices were going to be high we don't
know what they're going to be in the
future there's a reason why we at the
new economics Foundation have called for
a great homes upgrade retrofit every
single home insulate them and ensure
more renewable sources but actually
there was no plan at all this energy
price freeze when it came out we don't
know what gas price are going to be what
we do know is we are dependent on them
right now so we should have been
planning for the future and this
government has not done that at all but
even could the government get lucky and
could gas prices perhaps not go as high
as forecast and of course we know that
the cap does bring down the rate of
inflation yeah that's a gamble that
households are going to pay for and not
this government right absolutely you
know you should absolutely hope for the
best but you prepare for the worst
that's a responsible thing to do and
what a responsible government would have
done when they had their first budget
and their energy price freeze Greg I
thought we just got a follow-up to that
thing just uh time for it before we go
to a break from Lee and this is the
question we touched on it how are the
government going to choose who to help
in April with energy bills my wife and I
both work full time and still won't be
able to afford more and I suppose that's
exposing the thought that then perhaps
the the the help might be targeted to
people on benefits and and exceptionally
low pay what we saw from the previous
but one Chancellor issue soon a previous
but two Chancellor I'm losing count um
we saw in his April statement exactly
that targeted support clearly uh some
support for everybody but targeted
support for those on Lower incomes and
those in particularly tough spots and I
wonder whether that's not a pattern for
what we're going to see under let's call
it the return to Orthodoxy under Jeremy
Hunt we just don't know yet and I
suspect neither does the treasury
because they're going to take their time
to figure it out and they're going to do
so and what we do know as they said very
clearly today is Hunter very clear this
morning is they're going to do so with a
specific view as to the affordability of
any scheme so I think we've got to
understand that there'll hopefully be
some Humanity in that proposal but also
a lot of prudence it's also worth noting
it's not only households middle or
higher income or indeed low-income
households who are facing a period of
extremely high uncertainty it's also
businesses because of course they were
only are going to give get cut until
April so there's a huge amount of
General uncertainty facing the economy
and households after April okay listen
we are going to take a pause now to
absorb all that you're watching Sky News
Tonight coming up we're still continuing
this question and answer session will be
asking amongst other things uh what
Solutions there are for the current
economic turmoil and looking in
specifically at pensions
[Music]
look at that sheet of flight and it's
moving this way and over there is Dover
we track the changes happening to our
world right now I think it's a
procession of the Taliban there they are
right here would you as prime minister
be able to look them in the face let's
have a look at both of those two things
I just want to say thank you for having
the courage to speak to us we do
genuinely believe in what we do to show
the truth
I thought there was an astonishing story
there
big stories don't always come from big
cities
I'm Lisa Dowd and I'm Sky's Midlands
correspondent and this is where I grew
up we can reveal that the driver who hit
Harry Dunn is 42 year old and sakulas
just met the president and we never
thought we'd get this far this is what
they're up against that the wind is the
really big problems it is back breaking
work and the smoke is thick
working well water levels are dropping
but no one knows what impact further
rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open so
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world it's really scary
we're terrified
in this community I'm told that
everybody knows someone affected by
covid hopefully this will be the last
wave
amazing change seems tantalizingly close
in this corner of the UK Wales was the
first to introduce the plastic bag
charge
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
[Applause]
to try and make sense of issues that
affect you 9pm 9pm 9pm is the soundtrack
to your weeknight on Sky News
[Music]
welcome back as you know we're answering
your questions about the chancellor
statement today and what it could mean
for your finances of course as well as
for the state finances that of hm
treasury still with me our Greg Marsh
founder and CEO of the cost of living to
announce given sander head of Economics
at the new economics Foundation Think
Tank and Sue Hayward consumer affairs
and personal finance experts uh good to
see you all again uh refreshed after the
break we're going to discuss pensions
now we've got this question uh
basically in it's been I suppose at the
heart perhaps of the economic turmoil
company pensions to even you know part
of the the problem the intervention by
the bank of England was to support
company pensions it would do something
that I think not a lot of people
understand in terms of gearing uh on the
guilts that they held so the question is
is my Company pension safe so at the
moment very much so look it's kind of
inconceivable for either the bank of
England or the treasury to allow Pension
funds to go cost is why we saw such a
huge intervention in the markets by
Andrew Betty when it came out and it
looked like it was about to go wrong
they were absolutely standing behind
them and on the other side of course
they have withdrawn that support and it
looks like Pension funds are safe
they've kind of reordered their own
Investments you know they had an
investment strategy that was prepared
for certain things what they weren't
prepared for was such huge increase in
interest rates almost overnight it was
completely out of kind of sample where
their modeling Got to Now there might be
questions about regulation but for the
moment those funds do look safe and so
what about term I mean most people don't
have a Company pension anymore what
about uh money purchase so or once you
administer yourself if they're stock
market linked they're taking a bit of a
hammer I was going to say even private
pensions anybody who has a pension who's
thought oh let's have a little look
online right now they're going to be
obviously really gutted because of
course the stock market turmoil means
that your pension yes is very likely to
have fallen if you're the sort of person
who maybe checks it on a monthly basis
or something like that you may well have
seen fools having said that you know I
know it sounds one of these things we
sort of Trot out but you know the stock
market does pick up pensions will
gradually pick up just because you've
lost money seemingly overnight doesn't
mean that obviously unless you need your
pension that second you're going to lose
out so the advice is of course to leave
it in there not start to try and pull
any out or start panicking you know
withdrawing it looks talking about
anything like that which of course in
theory once you're 55 you can take some
of your pension out but it's it's not a
great move to start reading your pension
pot at any stage what about the state
pension Greg question here just asking
will Jeremy Hunt honor the triple lock
next April just explain that that's the
triple lock it's what 2.5 percent wages
or inflation whichever's higher exactly
and and under any other circumstances
we've seen how sort of how hot a topic
this is and how how anxious the
government's been to maintain
particularly given of course the voting
intentions of a lot of those pensioners
are more likely to be core conservative
votes I'd say if I were a betting man
I'm less phlegmatic I'm less confident
about the government's willingness to
stand behind that lock right now than I
would have been before Jeremy hadn't
seemed to indicate today that he might
look at it well look I mean we've seen a
government very visibly over the last 24
hours and the last few days under threat
from the markets demonstrate it when the
circumstances change when the Market's
demand change it will adapt so I would
not be complacent about that and I think
that ultimately the government will do
what it has to do and it's not only
pensions we should have in mind it's
also that you know this long-standing
commitment there has been to raise
benefits that's our next question from
Tracy let me just put it to you will
benefits be increased in line with the
the cost of living a hot debate at the
moment because the decisions coming very
soon isn't it is it going to be
inflation cost of living all wages of
course the increase in wages is lower
and it'll be determined based on the
data we're going to get this Wednesday
from the bank from the ons the offered
International statistics who are going
to be giving us the CPI numbers on
Wednesday morning it's a big question
and although the the absolute amounts
don't sound like they're enormous for
for a household that depends on
universal credit or other state support
it's a big deal the difference between a
5.5 rise and a probably roughly 10 rise
in those Universal Credit sums could be
the difference anywhere between 15 40 45
pounds depending on the family
circumstances a month it's a huge amount
it's a huge amount of money and we don't
know whether it's gonna allow any
thoughts on that which way do you think
the government will go on that obviously
I would like to see them go with
inflation but right now when they're
penny pinching and pulling everything
back I don't know what they'll do I
would like to think they would simply
because they are taking away so much and
right now with as we said with the
energy price guarantee and everything
else I would think surely they've got to
do that at least give some money back
especially to the lowest income people
who are going to be hardest hits when
the price comes and they should and they
should do so right so we already have a
hunger crisis in this country 2.6
million kids going hungry and that
number is only Rising the people who
suffer the most from benefits not being
upright in line with prices are the most
vulnerable it's children the severely
disabled and pensioners because they
can't work to make up a difference
between lower pension payments and
higher prices and when Jeremy Hunt and
the chance and the Prime Minister talk
about difficult decisions we should
remember it's not difficult for them
they will not suffer in the way that
those people the most vulnerable people
in this country will suffer that would
make a difficult life more than a
difficult life listen we've got a big
test for you all to end this session
you've all been so brilliant this from
Tom C and thank you very much indeed for
this one Tom let me read out Tom's
question are there any measures that
would help fix all this without
punishing the less well-off and trashing
the economy again it haven't been
considered yet we're going to ask you to
do the the treasury's work for it let's
stay with you Jim because you were more
or less on that path you've got to um
you've got to fix all this in two two
minutes without punishing the less
well-off well the key here first and
foremost is absolutely put money into
the family's Pockets who are struggling
because they spend it down the shops
they don't save it in their bag
and at the moment you remember the
terminal we're seeing is not about
financing it's about the fact that they
have this incompetency premium you know
we spent 400 billion pounds during covid
there was no bond market meltdown
because it isn't a financing issue this
is a we don't know how competent the
government is or rather we know they're
incompetent that's what they are
secondly you invest in people and places
and finally have a plan to get energy
bills down what you definitely don't do
is repeat the same fail play but we've
seen for a decade public spending cuts
that's made us poorer and also less safe
and less healthy competency and and a
plan so very quickly if you can what I
would like to see when I'm thinking of
household budgets is that they actually
make a rule that the lenders have to be
tolerant and offer you mortgage payment
holidays in the same way they introduce
them during the pandemic there was only
some lenders to actually do that rather
than you have to go kind of begging cap
in hand to your lender and say please
can I do it and it's at their discretion
if they made a rule like which is soon
acted once before and said look they
have to do this for a limited time you
can apply for it I think that would help
ease the finances of a lot of people yes
you've got to pay the money back yes you
pay it with interest but it would just
temporarily ease the budgets and
finances
on those lenders they're making a lot of
money as well certainly they are you
know it's one of those things but I just
think at the end of the day you know
lenders make their own decisions
sometimes when it comes to who they give
the paints Greg last thoughts on on this
the big question uh fix it all without
punishing the less well-off there's no
there's no silver bullets in life
there's only lead bullets I would like
to see a government go far tougher on
companies who are ratcheting up their
prices ahead of even CPI inflation
levels the Broadband companies the
mobile phone providers and there's a lot
of very cheeky Behavior going on there
and I think a really firm line from the
government would put some pounds back
into people's pockets and there is an
argument for a windfall tax but look
households especially those affected by
today's announcement the advice is very
simple right control the things you can
control there's lots of stuff you can't
control right now there's lots of of
uncertainty make a provision today
saving is the new spending make sure
you've got something square of the way
if you can because goodness we're going
to need it in April thank you all very
very much indeed we're out of time Greg
Marsh Stephen sander Sue Hayward very
good seeing and hearing from you some
great advice there you're watching Sky
News Tonight coming up in the next hour
at eight o'clock we'll have much more on
the Chancellor's statement today versus
we'll be getting reaction from a
conservative MP
[Music]
thank you